Você sabia que o arroz quentinho que
você come todo dia pode estar sabotando
seus níveis de açúcar do sangue? Pois é,
Rafa descobriu um truque simples que
muda tudo. Olha só, o arroz branco que a
gente adora é praticamente puro amido,
não é? Quando você come, ele vira
glicose rapidinho e seu pâncreas tem que
trabalhar dobrado para produzir
insulina. Mas veja bem, os pesquisadores
de Harvards descobriram que se você
deixar o arroz esfriar na geladeira,
acontece uma mágica chamada
retrogradação. O amido fica resistente,
ou seja, seu corpo demora mais para
absorver. E tem mais. Se você adicionar
um pouquinho de azeite ou ainda de óleo
de coco depois de cozinhar, o efeito
ainda melhor. Isso reduz o índice
glicêmico e ajuda a prevenir diabetes
tipo 2. Então é isso, cozinha o arroz,
adiciona um fio de azeite, deixa esfriar
e pode até comer no outro dia. Testa aí
e me conta se você notou diferença na
sua energia. M.